he's setting him up for the black arrow  which he transitions into the brutalizer  pack is looking to punish orange Cassidy  there you go into rubbing away that's  the only thing he could do  he's speaker right it's why they call  him the king of sloth style look at he's  back the marks on his back already from  this right I love it  as a very effective counter ladies and  gents he hit the he dodged two bullets  and seemingly it's all he's got right  down they look at him he can't even get  up off the floor  [Applause]  practical Sevilla chasity  there's not perhaps get really  frustrated he's searching around the  ring  Oh Cass Cassie stops  fans are loving that  [Applause]